I feel like a boyfriend now this is the
first time I'm like this is what it's
like to be a boyfriend we're trying on
boyfriend jeans and by we he means he's
trying on boyfriend I'm trying the more
boyfriend jeans are like jeans that are
like little looser on girls he's
actually worried that he's gonna fit
into them really what I am and first I
put it in that kneeling and then I'm
wearing girl jeans that fit me as a man
that's not I'm nervous I think it seems
like a common mistake that could happen
like a Nordstrom walking around
boyfriend jeans I'm a boyfriend I'm
gonna try on these jeans I got a big
butt so you know I don't think he's I
don't think these jeans are gonna get
over that but but we'll see okay ready
let's do it
they look a little weird I don't know
why but they don't look that weird I
like them you do I like them actually
they're kind of rugged looking you know
very plain I would say there's nothing
like exciting about these I love these
like I'm not gonna lie I might put the
bill for this and rock these out so we
go rummage a place to pick up football
outside I'm shocked I'm feeling good
right now yeah boyfriend's would not
wear this color what is this loving the
fit because it's it's loose in the
crotch area but it's tight right here so
it's like skinny jeans 2.0 feel a lot
more active all of a sudden look at that
look at that knee action how high it's
gettin if somebody come at me you can
get some neat you know okay you all girl
jeans are they as useless as this
because like these pockets do nothing
that's a normal woman pocket okay well I
don't know they're a little short you
know I wear a lot of fancy socks so
that's actually a plus for me look at
this hole in the upper thigh
I like this the sudden this looks cool
who designed this whose idea was that
right there hmm
is right there you see my underwear your
butt doesn't look good
my butt is look good to me no why oops I
dropped something oh yeah oh nothing to
be honest I don't know what it is look
like I don't like them ah him they're a
little different they fall a little bit
differently her jeans tighter than this
no yeah my jeans are tighter than this
do you mean that's like watching much so
so I think boyfriend jeans might also be
for boyfriends I'm just throwing it out
there I am not pleased with this
boyfriend Jean thing I see where they're
going for and uh he likes this boyfriend
thing way more than I do I like it yeah
I'm one of your dude pants if you wear
girl pants well these aren't girl pants
these are boyfriend jeans don't feel
like my jeans these are not my boyfriend
jeans these get the boyfriend seal of
approval from me I think so you know
these are women's were bought in the
women's department yeah but hey you know
if it looks good on me I can help
whatever it says